hi I'm Meredith Ashley I wanted to thank
you for joining today to listen to my
presentation I wanted to talk to you
about long-range sequencing and
infectious disease and how advances in
genome sequencing technology are
allowing new insights into infectious
disease genomes and are helping us begin
to make more progress against
long-standing challenges in this area so
it's no surprise to any of you who have
logged in that there are challenges of
many different types when it comes to
battling infectious disease some of them
are more social in nature for example
environmental degradation that leads to
increases in disease vectors poverty in
regions where infectious disease has a
high burden also political instability
and poor public health infrastructure
but there are also a number of
scientific challenges that combined with
seas and those would include lack of
laboratory model systems for parasites
with complex life cycles but also things
like the lack of a high-quality
reference genome which limits our
ability to understand the drivers of
drug resistance and also to identify new
targets and in addition to that it can
make it challenging to understand how
parasites or other vectors of infectious
disease are able to evade the immune
system and all of this is happening in
the context of the rapid emergence of
your alerts and drug resistance and so
and I wanted to kind of share with you
how some new technology is starting to
help us make a dent in at least some of
the scientific challenges so Peck bio
smart sequencing is a unique kind of
sequencing technology in that it has
four key characteristics that are quite
different from Shortridge sequencing
that you may be more familiar with the
first is continuity so the read length
of Peck bias equal zero very long over
30 KB and median length with some reads
as long as
Kibby we also have a very uniform
coverage of all genomic context no
matter what the GCR 80 richness may be
they really have very high accuracy and
are able to achieve QB 50 or 99.999%
accuracy with sufficient coverage
because we lack a lot of the systemic
errors that are introduced by the PCR
which is a component of short reads
sequencing and then finally PacBio
sequencing a single molecule which means
that we are able to detect rare variants
so how does this play out in the context
of genomes that are important for
infectious disease so I want to start by
going into some detail about Plasmodium
falciparum and how new better genome
assemblies have been able to move some
research forward in that field so as you
probably know malaria is caused by a
Plasmodium falciparum and malaria causes
almost half a million deaths worldwide
every year the Plasmodium genome is
organized into 14 different chromosomes
at a range of sizes and the first genome
assembly for Plasmodium was reported in
2002 using shotgun sequencing methods
and then previously there were
additional attempts with every ensuing
technology to improve or add to the
number of Plasmodium genome so one of
the things it's about this genome is
that it's very high 18 rich over 80%
across the entirety of the genome and
subtalar marek regions are particular 18
rates often up to 99% 80 rich and these
sub telomeric regions encode the hyper
variable multi-gene families that we
know are involved in both virulence and
also an immune evasion and in addition
to these homologous families there are
also large segments a very repetitive
sequence so as you can see from the
chart below here all
these previous sequencing technologies
were not able to do a very good job with
providing a reference genome that lent
researchers really dive into all of this
complexity so for example the number of
contexts for Sanger sequencing was not
so bad
several thousand context but attempts to
add to the number of strains that had
been sequenced with Illumina sequencing
or for five four pi or seeking
sequencing were very unsuccessful I
would say the Illumina sequencing
assemblies have over 20,000 contacts
each with the nkb contact size and it's
very small only 1.5 less than 2 KB in
length which is barely long enough to
contain a single intention let alone to
allow resolution of very homologous she
and families that are often chained and
and across large regions so enter PacBio
sequencing in 2016
Peck bio undertook some some
collaborative work to sequence the
Plasmodium falciparum genome and to
greatly improve the reference here and
so what I'm showing you here is the
overall assembly statistics for this
this genome and as you can see all 14
contexts are 14 chromosomes have been
resolved to a single contig and these
contacts stretch from telomere to
telomere and this means and not only and
I'm not significant and one of the
reasons that PacBio was able to do this
was because of those unique qualities
that we that I discussed before namely
namely the combination of very long read
lengths with low contacts bias was
really game-changing so as you can see
here the read lengths for this genome
assembly were very long and that allowed
us to span through these highly
repetitive regions and in addition to
that the low bias allowed even coverage
even across
the centromeric regions and in the
bottom panel what you're seeing there is
the coverage of PacBio reads across
contig 12 the entirety of Conti 12 all
the way from telomere to telomere and
what you'll see is that the coverage is
is quite high and very even across the
whole region and that and that's really
a game changer when it comes to assembly
so what is what was the benefit there
what is the what is the key advantage if
one of the the things that I think most
researchers will understand is that
oftentimes those regions of high
homology that are so difficult to
assemble are often the most important
ones to decode because they all of that
repetitiveness facilitates genome
recombination events and changes and
those parts of the genome can often be
under the most selective pressure and
where most of the exciting things are
happening in terms of what's going on
with immune evasion and drug resistance
in some cases and so one example of that
I could show you one example of that
which was highlighted in the paper right
and so here what you see is that in
chromosome 10 there's a 14 kb
duplication event that was apparent in
the smart sequencing assembly relative
to the Sanger reference and this changed
this duplication resulted in the
addition of three more riffing genes to
the Plasmodium genome and riffin genes
are mere appearance molecules that are
expressed on the surface of infected
erythrocytes during the mitotic phase of
expansion and these mediate the binding
of infected red blood cells to the
vasculature and where and there you know
undergoing antigenic variation and so
these genes are super important in
understanding the course of the disease
and also virulence and differences in
virulence between strains and and these
are the kind of insights that are now
possible when you have a fully assembled
genome that includes those sub telomeric
regions
genome assembly was published a
additional 15 Plasmodium isolates were
later assembled also attacked by
technology and also to to near
completeness and in this case five of
these were laboratory Slains 10 were
clinical isolates and what you'll see if
you scan down is that all of these
contain the telomeric sequence and most
of these are a number of these have
chromosomes in which both telomeres are
also attached so all these are
high-quality assemblies and also allow
the type of deep dive and analysis into
real biological problems that was so
challenging with the less continuous
genome assemblies highly contiguous
assembly that makes the short read there
that you haven't had much more useful
right because when you have short reads
and the they can be mapped to a higher
quality assembly and allow for you to
understand whether the data contained
within those reasons whether those genes
have been rearranged or in their same
place or whether there are additional
variants and all manner of questions
like that are a lot easier to address
once you at least have a high quality of
reference genome that you can use to
analyze those strains and the author's
point out here because of the highly
polymorphic nature of the subtool
america regions and the internal bar
gene sequences most short reads from
these areas could not previously been
aligned to the reference genome and now
that there's a diversity of Plasmodium
isolates from all over the world this
makes this a lot more possible due to
the completeness of our assemblies it's
now possible to characterize other core
genes that have previously been
difficult to access with short reads
because these genes are too diverse to
be aligned well enough to enable
confident snip calling so a lot of times
people recognize that long read
sequencing the key advantage there is
that you are better to able
to see structural variants and
large-scale changes in the genome but I
just wanted to point out that having a
better genome assembly which requires
long reads also enables you to do better
snip calling right simply because you
can now map those short reads onto the
single correct place in the genome that
they are derived from and in that way
you can tell the difference between
genes and pseudogenes between genes and
new duplications and you can really
understand much better things like drug
resistance that may in fact be a snip
driven so one of the other things that
was highlighted in this paper is that
the the core genome in Plasmodium
falciparum is highly conserved and
there's a lot less rearrangement events
that happen in that core area whereas
the sub telomeric region is highly prone
to structural variation and one of the
things they wanted to identify is where
is the exact boundary between the core
and the sub tubular genome here because
they wanted to understand well which
genes exactly are subject to this higher
rate of structural variation and which
tend to be more concerned and so they
devised a cut-off point where the core
boundary delineation is defined as the
point closest to the telomere at which
eight out of 15 or more than half of the
Geno T types cease to align and so what
I'm showing on the left now is one
example for one of the genomes showing
how the left and the right telomers you
see that alignment is robust in the
central part of the genome but there's a
super sharp drop-off when you try to
align the other the new 15 genomes
against the original reference so that
cutoff is really abrupt and very sharp
and if you want to read more details
about the structure of that I encourage
you to to read the to read the paper so
again this all sounds very cool it's
very nice but if you're not a genome
we geek like we are hacked by Oh what
does that mean what is the point how is
that helpful to you well we are since
these assemblies came out a few years
ago we are now beginning to see
publications that highlight how the
better genomes are allowing new
discoveries so this is one example of an
article that I really liked and this is
about how a multi population genomic
analysis in shows that there's local
selection into differentiation at the
GDP one locus that seems to regulate
sexual development and may be involved
it may be under high selective pressure
so one of the things that interesting
about the GDP one locus is that
deletions in that area has been
associated with a loss of sexual stage
community genesis among laboratory lines
meaning that parasites with those
deletions I can no longer be transmitted
through mosquito vectors so to examine
whether I mean these naturally occurring
polymorphisms that they found here may
be present long resequencing data for
several isolates were then examined
including for some some new clinical
isolates so the first thing they did is
they had short read data that they
collected from 680 different clinical
samples that were collected from all
over West Africa and these were mapped
back against the new high quality
reference that was a simple pack file
and they looked at 32,000 different
snips wise these four linkage
disequilibrium to try to identify sites
in the genome that were under strong
selective pressure and what they found
if you look at the the charts here so
each time you alternate from black to
red you're moving into a new chromosome
and what you can see that a lot of these
hot spots for linkage disequilibrium or
strong selective pressure tend to be
towards the ends of those chromosomes
right so there's subtool america and
these regions were previously dark to
all of us because without an assembly
it's very hard to map data to those
regions and very hard to determine what
genes are actually located in those
regions that are under strong selective
pressure so what you'll see here of
course is that a number
and the hotspots that are coming up are
well known and are links to you either
chloroquine or anta folate drug
resistance but there are also some
interesting things that cropped up that
were not necessarily wanted to look at
it since they had these samples that
have been collected over such a wide
area of western Africa is they wanted to
understand whether the allele
frequencies of in these regions under
selective pressure had a geographical
pattern to their divergence and when
they narrowed it down those 30 mm sniffs
they found that only 17 had significant
geographical divergence and one the one
locus with the most exceptional
differentiation in chromosome 9
indicated by the arrow is linked to a
gametophyte development gene gbd1 and
particularly it's 3 prime intergenic
region so long read sequencing revealed
that there are actually two mutually
exclusive deletions near these
chromosome 9 snips and so the way that
they were able to ascertain this is that
they they made a kind of a dummy
reference that included both of these
deletion possible deletion events and
then they map back all of the data from
each of the clinical isolates to these
right and so normally that wouldn't
occur in nature right these are mutually
exclusive
but when you set up a a reference in
this way what it does is it allows those
short reads to very clearly map either
over the to the one region where it
exists in the reference here or the
other region here and so it becomes a
lot easier to to parse out which has a
deletion and which does not because the
reads assort quite naturally to the one
allele or the other also within this
figure here at the very bottom you'll
see is the reference genome for 4p
reichenau e and that was included as an
out-group and that is a species of
Plasmodium that
apes and and that has neither deletion
and it was interesting primarily because
it shows that this deletion event and
this by morphism has occurred subsequent
to speciation into the species that
affects infects humans so what are the
what are the differences in distribution
between these two deletion events so
what they found is when they when they
remap so these hybrid references they
found that the geographical distribution
of the alternative deletion in blue is
highly correlated with the allele
frequencies seen for the highest
chromosome nine snips right and so this
is interesting because you know this the
snips are easy to detect with short
reads but it was only by mapping a short
read data back to the high quality
reference genome that it was noticed
that they're these very large deletion
events right by the snips and so that
begs the question which is actually the
the genomic change that is under high
selection is it the deletion of it or is
it the snips that are in leakage linkage
disequilibrium with it which one is
actually causing a biological effect and
so this is not a question that they were
able to answer fully in this paper so
but there are some interesting hints so
the region that's near GDP one is known
to undergo deletions in some laboratory
adapted parasite isolates as I said
before and that causes those isolates to
lose the ability to infect mosquitoes
and there was a recent paper not this
paper that was shown that anti-sense RNA
can silence gdb one transcription and
prevent commitment to sexual stage
development and of course this deletion
event is happening in the 3-prime region
which means that it's entirely possible
that it's the anti sense RNA
sequence that is being impacted by this
deletion event so this certainly
provides some really interesting
operation
for scientific follow-up the authors try
to speculate what what might be driving
what what specific types of pressure
might be driving this differential
selection in Senegal and and Gambia
versus the rest of West Africa um could
it be differences in ecology so Senegal
and Gambia are much more coastal they
have a lot more brackish water that is
drawn into the river systems there
versus in more centrally located Africa
so that could be one difference are
there differences in mosquito vectors
it's known that the ecological
differences in Senegal and Gambia result
in different specific mosquito species
being present or absent and also that
those mosquito species can interbreed
and so it may be that this change the
sexual orifice might be related to the
need to be able to survive in several
different fly species could it be
differences in parasite and demand
amenity meaning how many of these flies
are actually infected with malaria so
interestingly there has been a big drop
in endemicity in Senegal in Gambia over
the last five years or so but the
authors thought of that and they went
back and they got some bain't
older samples and they found that the
lyric lilyc differences proceedure
predates the drop in any missing sneeze
so they think that maybe that's not the
case maybe it's not related to you know
I need to try to survive until there's
enough mosquitoes or enough
opportunities to to reinfect so I got
unsolved question and you know for me as
a scientist that the best discoveries
are the ones that you build more
questions than answers and this
definitely falls into that camp so of
course malaria cannot infect people on
its own it needs the help of the
mosquito and interestingly there's also
some recent improvements in the Massino
genome assembly using pipe file and
so similar to Plasmodium it is a chip
tied genome is highly repetitive if you
look on the left here the pie chart
shows that the vast preponderance of the
mosquito genome is comprised of ltrs
retro transposon signs mites
unclassified repeats and even simple in
tandem repeats and only a very small
part is you know easy to assemble with
short-range sequencing and as a result
of that if you look at the bottom left
you can see the difference between the
short read assembly that researchers
were working with in the past versus
what they didn't have now at the peck
pile assembly so the way that the
assembly continuity is rendered here as
an each little box corresponds to a
single content right and the contact
size at the right is the scale is shown
and so what you see that the short
assembly it's all black because the
boxes are so small you can barely even
see where one content goes to the next
but the PacBio assembly all three
chromosomes are very well organized and
ordered and the contact number decreased
from over 37,000 contains down to just
2500 decreasing the contact and 50 from
84 thousand base pairs all the way to 11
point 8 mega bases so now we have much
better ability to look into this ETA's a
[ __ ] genome and understand what's going
on and how how that mosquito genome may
be interacting with the Plasmodium
genome so the reference genome the
publication went into a fair amount of
detail about all the different types of
gene families that can now be annotated
with this higher-quality reference right
and so of Interest particular interest
to these authors was the enormous class
of ordering receptors gustatory
receptors and ion atrophic receptors all
different kinds of chemosensory
molecules that are highly diverse and
also very homologous this is kind of
like the worst case scenario the most
difficult to assemble part of the genome
and they wanted to point out what a
bang-up job longer sequencing did with
that
buying all of these if you look along
the bottom the part the pie charts here
are showing that the things in black did
not change from the old to the new
reference but everything that's in gray
right is merged meaning the short read
assembly was not able to to tell whether
you were looking at the same gene or
different gene and so in some cases you
had two copies of things that really
were just one gene and then similarly in
red these are all new genes that were
newly discovered identified and
annotated in the higher-quality assembly
and some of these gene families in
particular the ionotropic receptors here
there was just an enormous number of new
genes that were that revealed so maybe
more of more interest to people that
work in the infectious disease area
would be serine proteases or
metalloproteases so these proteases
mediate either immune responses or the
metalloproteases are linked to vector
competence meaning whether the fly is
able to serve as a host for for malaria
or not and what they found here just
briefly is that half of the 404 serine
and Metallica's protease gene models
were improved in the new reference and
49 novel proteases were discovered so
hopefully and this was only just
published in 2018 and hopefully this new
reference will yield new insight into
all kinds of of things that are
important for infectious disease so
here's one example which i think is is
highly interesting as with the
Plasmodium having this high-quality
reference has facilitated work in
population genetics so not only did they
sequence one reference genome they when
they took all kinds of population data
short read data that they had previously
and they used a new reference to
leverage that data to identify sites in
the genome that were under high
selective pressure and one thing that
they identified are some some hotspots
that are under a selective pressure for
insecticide resistance and they did this
five studying mosquitoes that are either
resistant or not resistant that are
located in Mexico
and what they found is that there's a
number of snips on chromosome three that
do indeed correlate with Delta Metron
resistance and these snips enter on a
new proved gene model of voltage-gated
sodium channel gene VG SC right and so
in the old reference this gene was not
well assembled so while you could see
that parts of this genome were under
selective pressure it was impossible to
know that all those snips actually
located to that to that specific gene so
hopefully this is only the first of lots
of discoveries of this kind that are
going to help researchers hone in on
genes that are most important not for
things like insecticide resistance or
vector competence and and in the area of
vector competence not shown here but I
encourage you to read the paper there
are a number of quantitative trait loci
on Cron's on two that were linked to
systemic dengue fever dissemination in
mid got infected mosquitoes so also very
promising okay so that kind of covers
what I want to say about plasmodia but
i'm plasmodia it is a chips are not the
only genomes that are important to
infectious disease Reacher's which have
recently been improved with the help of
longeron sequencing so there have been a
number of publications recently focusing
on trypanosome genomes so bama zones are
another kind of parasite and that caused
a number of diseases including
Leishmania and sleeping sickness among
others and so here's an example of new
IT crews i assemblies of two different
strains tsetse and DM 28c and what
you'll see here is that these with very
reasonable amounts of coverage these
have now been assembled and there's been
an over tenfold improvement over the
previous short read assemblies and
several of the contexts from this
assembly correspond to entire
chromosomes much like with the eat as a
chip die genome and the assembly reveals
a tremendous amount of genome complexity
much greater complexity for multi copy
gene families related to infection
processes and disease development
including trance Alice's mucins and you
see the associated surface proteins and
as with the Plasmodium genome it was
found that a lot of these multi copy
families are located in the telomeric
regions where they are likely under a
very high evolutionary pressure and
subject to frequent changes and
rearrangements and so this this article
was only published in 2018 and I think
it's only the the beginning of new
information that I'm sure researchers in
this area are going to be able to
leverage to start to understand exactly
what's going on with these multi copy
gene families and how they relate to
drug resistance and virulence among
other things here's another example of a
Japan's own improved reference genome
and and this one is which is a really
terrific paper they came out in nature
over the past year T Bruce iPads of
sleeping sickness and what you see here
is that the genome was almost completely
assembled and very highly ordered so
every time this flips the the gray bars
underneath the coverage plot flips that
is a different context but all of the
contents are organized in order and in
all cases most cases you can see in red
the sub to America regions where V s G's
which are the surface antigens on
sleeping sickness called variant surface
glycoprotein proteins all reside right
and so once again as with Plasmodium the
these highly polymorphic gene families
that are critical to immune evasion are
all located in these very hard to
assemble sub telomeric regions which are
now accessible with PacBio and the new
reference contains particularly
interesting here is that so these genes
are only transcribed when one at a time
they are mutually exclusive and they are
only transcribed when they have been
transposed or located within a telomeric
bloodstream form or a back
expression site and so one of the
challenges before is that neither
neither the sub team Eric vsg dense
regions nor the best sites were well
assembled in the prior genome and now
they are both very well assembled in the
new genome and once again I don't have
time to go into great detail here but
the authors were able to use a
combination of longer sequencing and
also hi-c and single-cell sequencing to
understand how these two parts of the
genome interacted together and were
subject to rearrangement events in order
to cause that antigen switching which is
known to make it so difficult to treat
sleeping sickness and to develop a
vaccine against it so once again I
encourage you to read this paper to
learn more about how how the better
reference has allowed new insights into
how sleeping sixes advanced immune
system so switching gears a little from
parasites to bacteria now so some of you
may already be familiar with Peck bio
because of our work with bacterial
genome assembly and I wanted to
highlight one particularly interesting
project that was completed recently with
the Wellcome Trust and the NCTC so the
NCTC is a part of public health England
and their mission is to collect and
preserve strains that are important to
human health and to hold these as a
resource that is available to the entire
scientific community in order to help us
understand how bacteria evolve and
change over time and also to provide
references so that an organized and
study and new bacterial strains and more
virulent strains that that are that are
arising all the time and so when Sanger
decided that they needed to have better
reference assemblies for their entire
collection they decided to go with
PacBio as the long resequencing partner
and the reason they chose us it was for
all of the reasons that I've already
been discussing with respect to the
Plasmodium and
namely we are able to sequence through
both GC and eighty rich regions we can
give access to complex regions of the
genome including is elements and phage
insertion events are data maps to both
repetitive genomes and is capable of
detecting structural variants including
gene loss gene insertion transposon
rearrangements and even better we are
able to characterize methylation pattern
at the same time and sequencing finally
we can detect minor variants so and I
have any examples of customers who are
able to find drug resistance that's
merges very rapidly even in culture
condition and then we are able to do all
this very quickly with this 210 hour
runtime and without introducing any
amplification bias or PCR errors so they
have so far extracted DNA from over
3,000 strains from 852 different species
and 82 different families and you can
see on the right that this encompasses a
wide range of the bacterial clad
sequencing began in 2013 and was
completed last year but they continued
to sequence additional genomes that were
outside the scope of the initial 3,000
that were targeted for improved
reference genomes and most of these were
assembled into very few contains and a
number of them also had the plasmid
sequenced and closed the impact of all
this has been pretty profound in terms
of the quality of information that is
now available with the NCTC
type strain so the vast majority of the
type strains now have complete reference
genomes and prior to this a large number
of them had no whole genome sequencing
data at all for the entire species so
not even just the strain that's banked
with NCTC but for any member of the
species at all and then 30% of those
strains there was no previous type
strain that was available and that's
challenging because often times
when the type strain has not been
sequenced it's it's sometimes it is
discovered the type stream is actually
not very representative of the other
members of the species that have since
been collected and studied and so
sequencing these type strains and making
sure that they are the correct in group
for researchers to use as they try to
drill down into what makes one strain
virulent and and the other drug
resistant is super important so we're
very happy to work with them to start to
fill in this gap in public databases and
to really enable researchers to do a
more robust study and you'll see here
that NCTC is very much focused on
strains that are relevant to human
health and this includes of course a
number of species that should be very
familiar to people that work in the
infectious disease worlds including
influenza diphtheria dysentery
meningitis and then the one I wanted to
talk about in a little more detail there
Bo cholera so just this past week there
was an article in in the press about the
sequencing of an additional NCTC strain
NCTC 30 which is a non pandemic Vibrio
cholera isolate that was collected back
in 1916 from a housefly World War one
patient who was reportedly suffering
from diarrhea and this is an interesting
time point to collect because this was
right at the end of the 6th cholera
pandemic we are currently in the seventh
or some might argue that we're past the
seventh and we may be entering an eighth
pandemic but in any event this one was
super interesting because while we have
a number of strains that were collected
during the height of the pandemic this
one is interesting because it's toward
the tail end and of course it's
interesting not only to know what
strains look like during the height of a
pandemic that also how they might have
changed or evolved as these pandemics
came to
and very few cholera isolates are
available from this time period so it
makes for a very interesting and
valuable isolate to do genome comparison
studies so the really interesting thing
about this genome is that it lacks in
the pathogenicity islands that are found
in classical v cholera
so it's missing so here you have a
comparison between this train and CTC 30
on the bottom of the chart and another
strain which is far more typical of
Vibrio cholera and what you'll see is
that there is a large genome inversion
that has happened on the chromosome here
and during the course of this inversion
a number in addition to the inversion
event some of these pathogens the
islands were simply lost so here where
it says CTX gene you'll notice that at
the top strain there's just a white spot
and what that means is that there's no
corresponding sequence and CTC that is
mapping back to that bacteriophage
region it in the VP one and and VP VPI
one and two two different paths and it's
just in the islands there's they are
appearing in white with no green lines
connecting NCTC 30 to the reference
train because those sequences are not
present in this very unique strain of
Cholera so that's very interesting to
note that this patient was sick with
diarrhea even though these very
important pathogens just the islands
were missing also very interesting is
that while NCTC 30 which was collected
in 1916 preceded the penicillin era it
is resistant to beta-lactam antibiotics
and it harbors a gene that is almost
nearly identical to be la herb 7 and
differs only by two base pairs from from
that so again very interesting
evolutionarily and that a lot of
antibiotic resistance genes were already
in circulation
even before the anti advent of
antibiotics and it really drives home
that you know back
he exists in a constant state of warfare
not just with us but with each other and
so not only are there a great place to
find antibiotics but they're a great
place a great reservoir for antibiotic
resistance as well so I wanted to close
by sharing with you that in the next two
weeks we are going to be releasing our
next sequencing system the system it's
called a single tooth system and in the
key difference between it and the
current sequel system is much higher
throughput it has eight times as many ZM
w's meaning it can sequence eight times
as many molecules at once it has still
this very same long read length from the
previous system the very same high
consensus accuracy and also the very
same high uniform coverage the only
difference is that the greater number of
Zn w's allows you to have much greater
throughput on a single smart cell so for
example here there's an example of
sequencing in e.coli strain in this case
we had 80 60 Cabezas of data in one
sequel to a 10 smart cell and for
comparison the sequel system would have
about 12 10 to 12 Giga bases of data so
much more data and similarly looking at
rice genome sequencing that again very
high yield in the mid mid 80 Giga bases
and even better the price point is a lot
more attractive as well so whereas the
sequel system they cost about $800 to
get that 12 Giga bases of data on the
sequel to system for about $1,300 you
now again 80 80 or more Giga bases of
data so I hope I've been able to
persuade you that throughout the history
of science I think
development of new technology has been
tightly linked to new scientific
discoveries as new technologies allow us
to address old problems in new ways
through a new lens and to make new
observations and PacBio is just one of
many new tools that are coming out and
we live in a very exciting era where
genomics
is improving so rapidly that it's almost
hard to keep up with the number of new
discoveries that are being enabled in
this area and so thank you so much for
listening to me and I hope that if I
feature interest at all and you go to
our website and check out all the
interesting kinds of research that are
being enabled with long-range sequencing
thank you so much